podría definirse en Georgia donde los
resultados de las votaciones de este
martes nos dieron como ganador a ninguno
de los contenedores según las leyes del
estado para que haya un ganador el
resultado debe ser superior al 50% de
los votos
hay una carrera en nuestro estado que va
a pasar a la segunda vuelta del 6 de
diciembre no nuestra oficina ya ha
comenzado el trabajo entre bastidores
para empezar a construir las papeletas
la disputa está entre el titular
demócrata Rafael warnock quien Busca la
reelección un pastor negro de una
iglesia histórica donde predicaba Martin
Luther King Junior y el aspirante
republicano
una antigua estrella del fútbol
americano que es respaldado por Donald
Trump y que ha visto salpicada de su
campaña por acusaciones de abusos
domésticos y de informes que dicen que
pagó a varias exnovias para que
abortaran en el pasado a pesar de ser
antiaborto el resultado de los
habitantes de esmirlan Georgia no los
tomó por sorpresa hasta
[Aplausos]
tengo que decir que no estoy muy
sorprendida No creo que la gente haya
acudido a las urnas de la misma manera
que la última vez creo que eso fue un
factor que quizás hizo que algunas
votaciones terminarán con resultados
Opuestos
esta será la segunda vez que va a
segunda vuelta en 2021 ganó su escaño en
las elecciones especiales donde se
enfrentó contra el demócrata John osoft
En esta segunda ronda los habitantes de
Georgia se pondrán a prueba sobre si
están de acuerdo con las actuales
políticas demócratas o si prefieren
respaldar a los republicanos